welcome to this video playing Joe Jenn
Joe Jenn from Norway I only have played
him two times so it feels like this much
more often if you'd like to frequent
opponent but sometimes you really often
this kind of judgments ok the bogo with
a 50 K and only 93 let's see how he mmm
I can do that why not let's get to the
normal pawn structure here I'm going
Bishop c5 not giving up the the bishop
an interesting
interesting I can play night fo actually
I was worried about 9f for him because
this on d to where the bishop is on
detune ok it did not happen let's see
Knight to e5 or yeah maybe e5f sec f6 is
of course also also a viable option ok
do I start this this each file stuff I
do come on h 5 h form this is really
possible here um should f5 or something
like that I can also go to 2g for by the
way yeah maybe why not get get pieces
near the King not exchange stuff this
Bishop on b6 wow it's not even trying to
to to blunt the bishop ok I are i'll
advance i definitely will
guy for surprise me maybe it's it's
perfectly okay but it made a made a
strange impression on me okay um let's
see is he playing age three or something
like that if i play 83 can he can really
take it
very very tough to to play should I play
a five it looks amazingly weakening okay
is this is really about peace play I
shouldn't really worry about e-cigs g6
just need to get everything is king yeah
now take on you for now this was this
was the big idea of the whole thing I
can also take on g3 by the way but ok
let's let's start with this um you know
I can take F to actually
check I was thinking that maybe f8 takes
g3 is even possible here with Queen h4
but ok my looks are not connected that's
really a problem
anyway poor Bishop g4 just take check
nite chef Ivan I mean I just take okay
it's going down ok so I'm playing Bishop
Bishop age 3 now right maybe I should
even take first check so that this is
actually threatening g2 it takes with
the night i'm going to play Queen h4 or
take a look it's both would the RG 3 is
a strategy to g3 buddy ok that's really
quite a threat ok um should I under
promote now or just get get the Queen
white exam I just get the Queen ER as
the it's the easiest it's after this you
reside there but after this i have i can
just just take on d8 if i want right
there there's no threat I just attack
here with with two with the rook the
hook up yeah I don't know this was maybe
not correct but it was very dangerous ok
the computer approves of this at least
after he formed which is not getting
good marks buy a stock fish H form King
edge 1 + f5 is stock fishes move that's
great yeah that's that something I mean
f5 looks so tremendously ugly in terms
of weaknesses but it if the computer
gives it out gives it in this position
it is probably the best move the most
forceful move at least went here fe for
where this looks like I'm cheating and
playing all the computer
Jack f2 yeah this is one hundred percent
stockfish what I'm playing and now you
are not taking it wants to take on a
tree immediately but this also wins
check Oh funny Queen g2 is only minus
two interesting check the point is look
at my queen if I if I play this he's
going to play this and Sundy whitis
attacking what is winning here so the
computer gives this check with the wind
for black yeah technically winning I'm
two pawns up and have the better minor
piece even even the night coming 36 is
not really helping Emma can come here
maybe c6 later I don't know okay so this
wasn't so clear then ah this is this is
strong I can just take the rook of
course this is chaz is the point I get a
new queen or we get check this this
position here with an exchange and a
couple of porns up ok this was nice very
satisfied with this game ok thanks for
watching